[Música]
hola
hola como estan hola mucho gusto
a lo largo de mi carrera deportiva así
me la pasé saludando a medio mundo
y cada vez que escuchaba ciertas cositas
me quedaba callada a qué me refiero con
esto
toda la gente
crea una imagen a través de lo que ve de
lo que escucha
y siempre escuchaba lo mismo que padre
la vida del futbolista
les pagan por hacer lo que les gusta
viven bien viajan por todo el mundo
conocen muchos lugares
tienen autos de lujo
viven en buenas zonas
tienen muchos followers en redes
sociales
salen en revistas de espectáculos
es más
hasta mi abuelita tiene una fotografía
tuya en la sala de su casa
y cada vez que escuchaba esto
simplemente me quedaba callado
reflexionando
si cada persona que me dice esto
abría sus ojos su mente su corazón
se dará cuenta que detrás de la etiqueta
de futbolista
hay cosas más importantes y
trascendentales
el fútbol no solo es pisar y correr el
pasto mojado sobre el pasto mojado
no solo es acariciar y golpear la pelota
no solo es anotar y festejar un gol
no solo es lo que el aficionado ve
el fútbol es un estilo de vida que
requiere de responsabilidad
esfuerzo disciplina constancia
dedicación pero sobre todo amor y pasión
hace muchos años
con una maleta llena de sueños e
ilusiones
muy joven salir de casa
mi objetivo
era llegar a ser jugador de fútbol
profesional me meta jugar 20 años
lo logré
pero nunca me imaginé que el camino
estuviera lleno de enormes vicisitudes
en mi vida y sobre todo en la etapa de
futbolista
te puede suceder a ti a ti
a cualquier profesionista padre o madre
de familia hermano amigo
mi mente mi alma mi corazón y mi fe
fueron puestos a prueba de manera
constante y sin interrupciones
y cada vez que me sucedía esto me
costaba aceptar el cambio y asimilar lo
que estaba viviendo
cómo manejas la presión dentro del campo
de juego
como asimilar las derrotas constantes
los malos torneos
las críticas por parte de la prensa de
la afición de tus seres queridos
como aceptas el retiro
qué pasa cuando repentinamente las cosas
cambian de dirección
cuando pierde su trabajo
cuando pierdes la beca de tu universidad
cuando de pronto empiezan a llegar las
deudas
cuando repentinamente la gente que
estaba a tu alrededor
simplemente te daba la espalda y te
abandonaba
como acepta la separación de pareja
como aceptas la pérdida de ese hijo que
esperabas con tanta ilusión
qué pasa cuando llegan la preocupación e
incertidumbre
el orgullo el ego
la desesperación
en algún momento de tu vida has sufrido
has perdido las ganas de vivir o
disfrutar la vida
pero qué es la vida
muchas personas
me han dicho que su línea de vida es
esto
y yo simplemente me quedo viendo
eso es la vida qué aburrido no
para mí la línea de la vida es esto
un constante subir y bajar experimentar
los picos más altos y alrededor más
profundos pasar de la felicidad a la
tristeza del amor a la desesperación
del placer al dolor
viven momentos en los que quieres que
todo se detenga
y esperas que todo termine
hablas y te quejas de la vida lamentando
te de las cosas que te suceden
cuesta aceptar las cosas
cuesta asimilar los cambios
pero la vida simplemente continúa
el universo está cambiando
constantemente tú estás cambiando
constantemente
habrá días soleados habrá días de lluvia
habrá ganancias habrá pérdidas
pero la vida es así
todas aquellas personas a las que
admiras tienen altibajos
no puedes evitar los altibajos pero
puedes cambiar la forma en que los ves
si tú cambias la forma en que ven las
cosas las cosas que miran cambian que
miras cambian
para muchas personas
la vida es bella mientras que para otras
resulta ser un trago amargo ya que la
adversidad llega y se presenta de manera
inesperada
todos quisiéramos que nuestra vida
estuviera llena de alegrías y de grandes
momentos
pero la adversidad forma parte de la
vida de todos nadie es ajeno al
sufrimiento
y muchas veces ese sufrimiento se
convierte en un canal de aprendizaje
mucho más rápido que la misma felicidad
por lo que abrazar
aceptar y superar lo que estás viviendo
es importante
para que la experiencia te ayude
y es que no basta con oír hay que saber
escuchar no basta con ver hay que saber
aceptar
y entender que siempre hay un más allá
y que ese momento
va a cambiar
este proceso lo manifiestas de diversas
maneras
contra las personas que crees que son
los causantes del problema contra tus
seres queridos
y hasta contra terceras personas que no
tienen nada que ver con lo que estás
viviendo
tienes que aceptar tu realidad y asumir
la responsabilidad de las decisiones
decisiones que tomas en el pasado
estoy seguro
que tu interés no está en disfrutar del
placer puede evitar el dolor
está en encontrar un sentido en la vida
y como encuentras ese sentido
siendo amigo de ti mismo
todo cambio comienza dentro de ti
tienes que aprender a escuchar
aceptarte amarte
a enfrentar tus miedos sus sueños sus
realidades
a conocer tus virtudes y tus defectos
sus fortalezas y tus debilidades
tus dones valores tus ideales
tu grandeza
viviendo el presente el aquí y el ahora
dejando atrás las cosas que te tocó
vivir en el pasado
y no preocuparte por la incertidumbre
del futuro
a asumir una actitud positiva
comprendiendo
que todo en la vida es temporal
disfruta
cuando las cosas vayan bien y cuando las
cosas marchen mal no te preocupes
este proceso puede ayudarte a cambiar
muchas cosas
soñando en grande
con esa hermosa sonrisa que te
caracteriza y que abre los corazones de
todo el mundo
creando un plan de vida
asumiendo un compromiso
dando pasos cortos que aumenten su
seguridad y tu confianza
para que puedas ver con otros ojos el
camino hacia tus metas y recordar que la
perseverancia prevalece cuando todo lo
demás falla
y lo que más me gusta
creando momentos de calidad
hacer de cada momento algo especial
aprovecha la oportunidad que te da esta
vida
de perdonar a la gente que te rodea
debe estar a esa persona que tanto amas
de abrazar a tus seres queridos
de disfrutar de un día de lluvia tomando
una taza de café
del olor a tierra mojada después de la
tormenta
de un atardecer con los amigos
del sonido de las olas
de la mirada de tu perro
pidiendo con un propósito
encontrando razones para vivir
buscando un sentido en la vida
a dónde voy que busco
qué voy a hacer
encontrar una razón para levantarte cada
mañana y vivir como si fuera el último
día de tu vida
y hacerte la pregunta que tengo que dar
para los demás que puedo ofrecer a los
demás
y sobre todo gratitud
ser agradecido
te ayuda a ver la vida desde otra
perspectiva
la gratitud
te hace grande
si enfocamos toda nuestra energía en
agradecer cada detalle del que si
disfrutamos
viviendo el aquí y el ahora
será mucho más fácil que encontremos el
camino hace un buen puerto
pero sobre todas las cosas
dando lo mejor de ti
un día
alguien me preguntó
cuál fue la mejor experiencia que te
dejó el fútbol
empecé a sonreír
y después de unos segundos conteste
la capacidad de hacer frente a las
adversidades de la vida
y superarlas
y ser transformados por ella de manera
positiva
las heridas más profundas pueden hacer
grandes milagros gracias
tú
[Música]
e